six days ago LittleBigPlanet 456 asked
for more online scary flash games so
because these sauce delivers I'm going
to do that right now along with some
funny and just straight-up creative
games they're all free and they're all
online and links to them are in the
description first the funny ones the
only point of this game is to make Harry
Potter and Hermione kiss before Ron
Malfoy or Dumbledore can catch them but
hey how about avoiding pop-ups that is
all you do in this game and as such it
is called
the realistic Internet simulator I don't
even know is hilarious each mission is a
completely new ungrammatical lolspeak
challenge click in Steve easy here we go
it's a wait it could stop it stop just
okay got it god I've got him but now a
couple scary games this point and click
game is based on Alice in Wonderland you
have to use and find items and trippy
ways to find your way out the only
problem is alice is dead something about
the art style in this game freaks me out
but really all you have to do is find
and click the play button
it gets pretty creative and weird
speaking of which let's cover some
creative games here you don't shoot
missiles you are a missile you move your
mouse to steer yourself an aim through
slots it's pretty disorienting but not
as much as the disorientation game where
the level warp skews and twists making
you dizzy and making it difficult to
move yourself around even with something
as simple as the arrow keys draw play is
my favorite type of game you get to
control your character with the arrow
keys and then draw the level yourself
avoid spikes and get creative with how
you draw yourself away from danger you
can even do it like this alright now
here's a game I played last night for
longer than I really care to admit in
this game you get a number of
territories and you can attack enemy
territories and claim them if your zone
has the same number of dice or more on
it than the one you're attacking when
you attack both zones have to roll their
die and if you have the highest sum you
win here's a game that looks just like
the perspective illusions I've shown I
and
you have to move your mouse to look
around until you're looking from the one
angle where the 3d cloud of floating
dots magically aligned to form what
looks like a flat 2d image now if your
brain needs a break and it wants funny
stuff here's a game where do you have to
be secret with your farts standing at a
bus stop
let gas escape but only when loud cars
drive by if other people catch wind of
your wind you're busted but if you don't
fart enough the gas builds up and your
body explodes just like in real life but
it gets worse here's a Japanese game
where you poke butts and avoid poop
which is a pretty good place to wrap
things up I love doing videos off of
your recommendations so if you have any
ideas about vsauce or vsauce to videos
you'd like to see types of images topics
you want cool facts on let me know in
the comments below or over at
facebook.com slash Vsauce ami until next
time thanks for watching but now I've
got a special treat for you screen team
show has a brand new music video out
with some excellent moves and some
excellent Optimus Prime to watch it
click the video and I'll see you guys
soon
[Music]
you